le tableau que je vais vous présenter un
tableau de gustave caillebotte il
n'était pas à la fin des années 1890 peu
de temps à voir la mort du peintre
c'est un tableau qui est important dans
les collections du musée léon dierx
puisque il a été donné par enfin il
provient de la collection m'embrasse
vollard et il est extrêmement
caractéristiques de ce qu'on appelle la
peinture impressionniste
cette peinture en fait qui avait été
détesté qui n'avait pas été appréciée
qui a pris longtemps avant d'être
reconnue aujourd'hui une peinture
complètement intégré dans la mémoire
visuelle dans notre mémoire visuelle
mais c'est une peinture d'avant-garde en
fait dans les années 1800 1890 ci
pourquoi est-elle d'avant garde parce
que tout simplement à cause de la touche
que caillebotte à utiliser ces voix sur
la latte bien ça sur la droite de la
composition où effectivement il a posé
des petits traits de couleurs les uns à
côté des autres dans une touche nerveuse
une touche extrêmement dynamique
il n'a à mon sens qu'il a il a peint ce
tableau avec avec une certaine rapidité
pour saisir en fait une scène plutôt
banal quelque chose qui ne raconte pas
d'histoires c'est le bout de son jardin
avec le portail au loin la scène est un
peu plus loin la flore et d'argenteuil
qui était le grand lieu des
impressionnistes et cette touche très
fractionnée très nerveuse et également
cette grande luminosité cette clarté
qu'il ya à l'intérieur du tableau est
caractéristique de ce qu'on appelle la
touche impressionniste
après il ya autre chose aussi notamment
si on regarde l'horizon l'horizon ne se
trouve pas au milieu du tableau comme on
pourrait le faire gratuitement mais
plutôt dans la partie haute du tableau
ça c'est quelque chose qui provient des
estampes japonaises que les artistes
européens à partir du milieu du 20ème
siècle découvre il s'en inspire pour
renouveler leur composition pour changer
leur manière de voir et cet horizon au
et dans l'héritage en fait d'eux des
estampes japonaises que les
impressionnistes et notamment
caillebotte avait pu voir
plus conditionnée avait pu apprécier